whoa
whoa whoa look at that dude hi Patrick
and me too this first trick is an easy
one all you need is a glass and a
computer and of course water you'll need
water for all of these tricks mmm
so Patrick take that water for me and
pour pour me a glass okay
oh no no no no don't drink it I'm saving
for the trip I drank a little that's
okay
so now we take our computer and you'll
see that we have an arrow here you know
which way is that arrow pointing going
this way to the right okay
grab your glass okay and lift it in
front of the arrow isn't that something
so this next trick is one of my
favorites I'm very excited for this trip
yeah all you need is a glass of water
rubber band a piece of mesh and
toothpicks so you take that bottle of
water for me okay put the piece of mesh
over the top take the rubber bit whoa
you're already ahead of me do you know
what you're doing I kind of see where
this is going and I want you to pour all
of that water into this glass but it's
gonna overflow there's way more water in
here that can fit in that laughs I guess
we'll just have to find out won't we
okay
there we go come on pour it out I'm
trying stump it in
[Music]
Wow look at that I'll take one of the
toothpicks here okay put it through the
bottom of the mesh
[Applause]
what the heck all the way through Wow
look at that
[Music]
dang dude huh so this is uh some sciency
stuff Oh looks like we're running out of
time so this will be our last trick okay
I have a bowl of water you could just do
me a favor and just dump some pepper in
there think of some spicy water just
dump it in stump it in okay like it
going fine Italian restaurants only
one's perfect
that's enough great I want you to put
your finger in that water
just put it in stick it in the water no
what I bought and I got pepper all over
my finger I played a mean joke on you
well that was rude
but let me show you a tip to never let
that happen again put a little soap on
your finger I love the idea that I might
be doing this again I'm good to go
no dunk it again do the same thing that
you did before whoa
swish around Wow what's the deal it
almost seems like a magnetic reaction
which I know it isn't the pepper water
does not want to go near my finger in
fact it's running away yeah look how
clean that is look at that clean finger
well this was fun I really learned a lot
I'm glad yeah thanks for showing me no
problem yes remember when you're doing
it at home to be safe and responsible
[Music]